Identification. This is Station three and it's the second side of tape three.
And if you became a few seconds and got it. What happened after better just.
I was a better story for quite a long time. Brings back beautiful memories because the locals were so good.
They were wonderful to us and on Sunday afternoon. They'd fight between themselves to have us for. Scums cream and tea.
So I left with a little regret I have to say I found it very difficult least because so because it was so beautiful.
And one thing I want to say about that castle one of them some local family had an eighty two grand piano for the uses
for the girls to use. And the coach was a very good pianist. But she could also play J.S.
So at the end of the day and a half to dinner at night we'd dance feet of each other in the ballroom.
So then I came back to Sydney and had some leave but I want to tell you. About being at the irrigation here.
And I don't really ever learnt about the irrigation area when I was at school and how the canals were built
and opened every so often. And these great massive orchards. Fruit watered.
And I often thought that if they could do that in that raid. On the irrigation area.
They could have done it in the center of Australia I suppose. But anyhow. I wanted to pertain to pick grapes. And.
Griffith. And we were OK I'm to a huge old Costello right in the heart of the town really.
And it took two hundred women. And my first job of course or most of us were all working picking grapes.
And the grapes would go to the William winery or was it painful.
But Williams I think well of course you had all of these young sophisticated women.
Picking grapes and there at the end of the day he having a little drink at the winery.
And the bosses would always say have one for the road.
You know don't have one for the road and sometimes turn up the choir I believe in kept. So I enjoyed working there.
There was one particular Italian family. Which employed quite a number of girls and they had a son.
I can't remember his name but he came knocking on the door the door in a farmhouse came to us
and he came knocking on the door. One Saturday afternoon.
And I asked the officer in charge if he could see me and she said Oh yes I suppose.
You know I think they're pretty easy. By then. Incidentally we were in uniform.
We had for her a year or eighteen months by. And in uniform. But anyhow this young man had some books.
And he said Faith.
I thought you might like to borrow some of my books
and I said I'd love to because there was never anything to read around the place
and we wouldn't even newspapers we couldn't get the Herald anything like that
and we both very dependent on radio while us as we called it
and we had this little while as we'd all flock around to hear the news. Well I rather work men bringing me to.
Good looking guy. Books to read for a few days past and I thought I'd better have a look at them and one was.
The origin angles origin of the family and the other was Mark's hand to poke on capital.
And I got stuck into things and I thought oh yeah I reckon there's something good in it. Anyhow.
You know why it was regretful but do you know why it was goaded I began the interview with.
A lot of do a lot of singing.
And I was doing a lot of practice with the local who would take me and the music you know they were very good.
This was while you were in the land me. Oh yeah sure. Griffith and Laden. Yes.
And I also did a couple of terms of piano. And shorthand. So when I was able to do that you know in the Land Army.
But the demand for me to sing quite considerable that.
Been singing like you know having lessons for quite some years and.
And I rather enjoyed this
but usually I would be asked to sing by the farmers near the family were mainly Welsh for the morrow.
They were very big. And they were the kindest people ever.
They'd sing of course in Welsh what language the world doesn't matter. They sing it. Well.
And I had a choir that move would move around from place to place and I'd go to church
and had a wonderful choir in the local church one of the local churches.
So I got involved with this lot and it was wonderful. I'd sing when I get married.
I would sing when I sing in the churches. And then one night I was singing at one of the local churches in little.
And a man in the. Soldier's uniform came up to me afterwards.
And he said I'm on leave at present and visiting friends here but would you come over
and sing to the boys over at Kapooka.
And I said What is Kapooka army came past side of Warga Oh I couldn't think of anything better. So I said.
In a few weeks a few weeks after that I asked the officer if I could have leave to go over because I had this
invitation to go over to work. And she said Now you know that you're working on Sundays now to get the apricot.
And afraid not. Well I want to have you. Together with two others and and they were so desperate for us.
They wouldn't punish us you see because they needed us on the field. You know to pick.
So we knew we could get away with it. So three of us set off. And we got the train from little to do you need.
And at uni. The blokes came and met us in an Army truck. And said they said hello.
We're not supposed to be meeting you in an Army truck because you've got. Do you mind if we throw this rug.
When we go through the gate to the camp. So you don't mind. So they took it to the hotel booked us into things.
And they were looking after the camp at Kapooka and to get through the gate. The guards would have a look.
Not where all. And so they mainly through the. Big Army top pole and so for us in the back and.
So we went into the camp. One they prepared a feast for us they had a captain who was a very good.
Element until I was hoarse and I kept.
And I got them singing with me and they cry just saying and every time we were with Home Sweet Home
and the tears would fall. And there was great sorrow the joy.
You wouldn't sing a little bit before you sang that night that completely completely you know what you don't know if
that but and so there was a man they had the name. Norton who are so nervous. And. Rather liked him.
So of very rich romance developed and this went on for quite some time.
So I kept going and he come over and it was absolutely wonderful and I take my mates. And I cook wonderful meals and.
It was great. So anyhow. I mentioned that man's name because I will deal with him in some detail in the book.
And not to forget. Mind you doesn't let me forget because when I was actually doing some work in commission in Sydney.
After forty years he popped up. As a habitat planning for. But that's another story. And that's something into that.
Did this singing.
You did you did you ever consider it as a career you obviously love performing I had no ambitions whatsoever none
whatsoever. But this person Norton.
Had access to the office mates which was in the big I think Commercial Hotel in Walker.
And everything was just laid on this. So he would take me there. With his captain. And I had a piano.
And I'd sing for the blokes and one thing. Someone said look at them. We will talk to the friend and.
Hundreds of people below. I want to move her and they started making their requests and they were calling out singing.
And I stood on the veranda and I sing to them. And I sing to please sing some. They were shouting.
And I just stood there and saying to them. And they were throwing flowers up onto the.
And I believe they are practically the whole evening.
And what it's like in country towns news passes around you see I've not been singing to the Blacks in.
In they miss in walking around you had a reputation. I had a reputation. I did indeed.
But they will because I left working out in the open. And the air would be Chris. And I would sing all day in the tree.
Whatever it was. It makes me think in fact if your father and mother will.
Your mother at any rate who sang around the house all day.
I sang around the house are saying around the camp all day
or wherever I was I had great friends in the in the women were some women are just so beautiful and lovely and kind.
And yeah I'd sing all day when I was working out in the fields and. Help to make the day go by.
But it wasn't you know it wasn't all that you're waiting carrot very backbreaking. And we'd be given a carrot.
For two months or three months just carrots backbreaking and you know it was eighty and ninety.
So I wanted it if it's still in my very first experience of singing around the place. But if the.